investigative journalist Bob Woodward
has announced he will be releasing I
believe it's close to 20 audio
recordings of his conversations with the
failed former president Donald Trump
some of these have started to trickle
out and they are disturbing now at this
point our threshold for saying something
Trump said or did is disturbing has
gotten quite High I mean looking at all
of the lists of things that he did it
really has to be something extreme to
get us to say wow that's crazy and that
is indeed what we have here let's start
with the first clip in which Donald
Trump tells Bob Woodward I have a plan
for dealing with the pandemic this was
from uh I believe July of 2020 but I
need to deploy it at a time that it will
help my re-election
not at the time where it would save the
most lives not at the time that it would
keep the most people healthy at the time
that it would be best for Trump's
re-election listen to this man more than
70 000 Americans had already died from
the virus now two months after that in
July Trump gave Woodward a ring and he
said he finally had a plan to deal with
the pandemic but Trump wanted to wait to
release it until a time when it would
better help him win re-election
[Music]
I've got 106 days that's a long time
you know if I put out a plan now people
won't even remember it I won the last
election no no but it's not just put out
the plan it's executed yeah I am
executed you'll see it starting
overtly
overtly saying if I do it now people
will have forgotten about it when it's
time to vote
not if I do it now I might save more
people now that's not a concern
disgusting guy completely amoral in
every way immoral in fact I would argue
um Trump Compares his meeting with Kim
Jong-un the North Korean dictator in
another clip
to the sort of instant feeling of
chemistry
when Trump meets a woman and just knows
whether it's all going to happen if you
know what I mean
listen to this you meet somebody and you
have a good chemistry and there is a lot
of strength to it
you made a woman
in one second you know whether or not
it's all going to happen okay we had a
very good chemistry together you meet
just strange I mean it's not it it's not
about oh it has romantic overtones
necessarily
although there is some
enamored feeling that we get from Trump
about these dictator types he seems
enamored with the way that President XI
of China deals with drug dealers he
thinks it's great he seems enamored in a
way with Putin's attitude and he
certainly seemed enamored with Kim
Jong-un now interestingly another
incredible moment from these uh
recordings is when Trump reveals
classified information to Bob Woodward
about weapon systems and the number of
weapons Russia has and he he is just
diarrhea of the mouth classified
information now I know oh the president
can declassify whatever he wants sure do
you think Trump is carefully considering
the impact and prudency of revealing
this information to what Rob Woodward no
he's trying to brag
we have stuff that you haven't even seen
or heard about we have stuff that Putin
and she had never heard about before
getting along with Russia is a good
thing that's a bad thing all right
especially because they have 1
332 nuclear Warheads
Trump just bragging to Bob Woodward
about all of the things that he knows
and then maybe incredibly Trump gives
Bob Woodward letters from Kim Jong-un
nobody else has them but I want you to
treat them with respect
and don't say I gave them please okay
okay
but I think it's okay normally I
wouldn't have give I wasn't going to
give him to Bob you know would you make
a photo stat of them or something no I
dictated them into a tape recorder
really isn't that the best what you make
a photo stat of the letters or something
um interestingly
Woodward is sort of handling the
documents with more care than Trump and
and what I mean by that is Woodward
isn't creating
physical copies that could then be lost
Bob Woodward seems to have more
consideration
for the sensitive nature of these
documents than even Trump himself these
are just four little Clips four little
previews of what may be to come from
these audio tapes I told you folks years
ago it will take years to learn the full
insanity of what took place during that
four-year period and indeed that is that
is the case it is taking years for all
of this stuff to come out and it is
disturbing as it is extraordinary as
many of you know I am fascinated by cons
and scams and multi-level marketing and
all of this different stuff I recently
saw Inside the Mind of a con artist on
curiosity stream it's six episodes and
it was excellent I don't think I would
have discovered it were it not for our
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream has all the newest and best
documentary films they've got the big
titles from the well-known filmmakers
they've got valuable into dependent
films tons of original content that you
can't find anywhere else when I'm at
home browsing my different streaming
platforms I find curiosity stream to
really have the best selection of
documentaries specifically because
documentaries is all that they have and
they're always adding new titles my
audience gets access to curiosity
streams entire library of documentaries
for just 15 bucks a year that's 25 off
go to curiositystream.com Pacman or use
the code Pacman the link is down below